the motions are running high amongst the
Brazilian President supporters as Jimmy
Rousseff held last minute meetings with
lawmakers she sent a key ally to rally
the crowd former president Lula da Silva
our fight is a fight for democracy for
respecting our Constitution and
respecting the rule of law Brazil's left
united in common cause hundreds of
thousands are expected to travel to the
capital for the vote some 4,000 people
from across the country are already
camped out here we are confident and we
will take to the streets to prove it if
we lose the fight for our rights will go
on we cannot accept impeachment the
politicians that are calling for it are
so corrupt themselves each must I say
that you feel sure just a few hundred
meters away a Rousseff impersonator
delights a crowd of opponents of the
brazilian president the president is so
alienated from the people that she's no
longer fit to govern she's forgotten
everything she promised during the
election campaign that's why I'm here
impersonating her and saying get rid of
me
but that on white German Rousseff
doesn't have the power to stop it
happening his supporters have to accept
that she's going to fall Brazil has had
enough of being humiliated in the world
stage we want a government that
represents the people both camps will
try to bring as many supporters as
possible to Congress in an attempt to
influence the vote and security is tight
this steel barrier will separate the
opposition from the government
supporters though those who are in favor
of an impeachment from those who aren't
in a way this wall symbolizes the
division in brazilian society